U obliku učinjenih primude
imamo pravne pravila,
to su ona pravila
koje imaju uređeno u pričavljeni države.
I obrenuli smo dva osnovna
principa pričavljenih države,
koja su pozvalno čelo subordinacija
i koordinacija.
Subordinacija je odnos na dređenosti
i podređenosti u imenu državnog radnja
na različitom stegljenom vlasti.
A kod koordinacije imamo ispravne glasi
i saraje.
To je ono što smo u prošlogu sad radili
i gde smo se zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje.
Kada je reč po ljudima,
krenut ćemo sa ljudima
da vidimo koji to ljudi rade,
šta rade, kako rade, kakav je njihov
odnos prema državi kao organizaciji.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini svo stanovni jezik.
Taj državni aparat čine
samo neke ljude. Ti ljudi
koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim spužbenim ljude.
To su ljudi
koji rade u imenu izračunog država.
E sad,
tim državnim službenim licima se
daje uopređeno poslovo.
Znate,
imate uopređeno državno službeno plice,
tako da radi neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegovu
radu.
Uvod u srpski jezik je jednostavniji,
ne da se držim definicije iz učbenika,
nego najprostiji je da ga objasnim.
Uzmeš neki posao,
daš ga jednom državnom službenom uvići,
kažeš evo ti, nadležnosti.
To je tvoja nadležnost, upravo to.
Postoje dve vrste nadležnosti,
u principu i ova treća nekako funkcionalno
te uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje, pa ćemo nju
objasniti, i prisutna je naravno u gradu,
u državnim škodanima,
ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvari,
ako uzmete jednog sudija
koji je državu službe novice
i jednog narodnog poslanika
koji je državu službe novice,
da li oni radi isti krivičanje?